you have to get permission to travel yes  even if it's to the next county over if  it's out of the city if you don't ask  for permission you could get the rest of  your probation time given to you as jail  time legally taking your son to school  you have to call get permission my son  lived in New Jersey but I let him for  the Delphian  the bridge is 15 minute ride it's just a  bridge I couldn't go get my son from  school when I wanted to because you know  some days I would get off work early I  would just have a free day and I would  just want to pop up at my son's school  and get home from school I've been out  of town for two weeks on the road  working can't really do it